The delay, but good afternoon. I am Council Member Edward Pollard
and I serve as Vice Chair of the City of Houston Budget and Fiscal Affairs
Committee. I called this meeting to order and would like to welcome Council
Member Abby Cayman, who is in person. All budget
workshops will be conducted in person. Only public
speakers have the option to comment in person or
virtually. Also would like to welcome staff from District
B, District F, District H,
District I, at large position three, and at large position 448
hours prior to the start of all workshop presentations,
materials are uploaded to SharePoint and hard copies delivered to
each council office. The budget workshop schedule has been posted to
the BFA website. Questions from council members can be uploaded
at any time during the budget workshop process, the earlier the better,
allowing the departments plenty of time to provide responses.
All departments have been directed to provide written responses
within 48 hours of the conclusion of their presentation.
To any question posted by council members to SharePoint,
all public speakers should be signed in to speak.
If you have not signed up, please sign in now.
At the front table, district E Staff Member Carolina will
be monitoring the public speakers list. Council members,
the fiscal year 2023 budget amendment template has
also been uploaded to the SharePoint Budget Workspace.
Mayor Turner sent out a memo to all council members and council offices
to ensure productive discussions on the fiscal year 2023
proposed budget reminder only operational
budget related amendments will be considered. Policy amendments,
as in years past, will be ruled out of order. Please see the
Mayor's memo for additional guidance. Amendments are due
on Wednesday, May 25.
We also have Council member Sally Alcorn in chambers.
In person? This afternoon we will hear from Legal
Department, Planning and Development Department,
administrative Office of City Council, administrative and
Regulatory Affairs Department, as well as the Municipal courts.
As a reminder, the only people attending virtually are public speakers.
We'll get to their questions after the presentations and questions from
council have concluded. At this time, I would like
to welcome City Attorney Arturo Michelle and Thy Ruiz to provide
the legal budget presentation.
The floor is yours.
Um, let's begin with
the second chart. This is the functional.org chart that we
have. This includes the different sections,
the overall and the dollars associated with them.
And this is from all three of the funds that
affect the legal department the General Fund, the Property and Casualty,
and the Workers Comp funds. It excludes
any positions funded by enterprise funds.
They're part of other department budgets, such as public works
and airport. The next slide
and the following one describe what we do some
of the major areas. Of course, everyone here at the table is intimately
familiar with it. I would like to point out that we
do deal perhaps more than other cities in
certain areas, such as planning and development issues.
We don't follow the zoning scheme, the regulatory scheme that
many cities do that presents particular challenges.
We often deal with regulatory or
statutory contract compliance. There are issues where the state challenges
us on preemption issue of water rights and so on. So we
have more activity than I think many cities do in that area.
Also, with our protection of neighborhoods,
again not being zoned deed restrictions,
that brings up particular issues that requires a lot
of investigation, assessment and analysis challenging
those entities or persons who we believe are violating the
law. And then we deal with a huge number of contracts and
the contract issues. And I would like to point out
now, although I could do it later, when I talk about some of the accomplishments,
that in contracts, in government contracting,
what is valued is transparency and
avoiding any fraud or other illegalities
that slows the process down. So we work constantly with
strategic procurement to try to do our best to improve the processes
and get the departments the contracts that they need.
The next page shows some of what I'm
talking about. And also our
labor lawyers, in addition to litigation,
have in fact their largest volume is probably the
adverse matters, the contested case matters that are not litigated before the Civil
Service Commission, issues before Department
of labor or EEOC, things of that nature.
In the following slide, it reflects
in part some of our priorities of the financial or societal impact
of service delivery. Our complete communities initiatives of
the city is one where we provide support
services. We try to do what we can to accelerate the process,
whether it's a transactional or whether it's an assessment and analysis of what can
be done. And then we anticipate growth in areas that
have been growing for a number of years now.
Public works with our aging infrastructure system and
our utility system, the airport system always has
new and pretty significant issues.
Housing is going to continue to be an issue here in Houston
and in most places in Texas for quite a while. The police department
with the onesafe Houston is
something that we have spent a big focus on, not only an ordinance,
but I would like to point out the Office of
Policing Accountability has been
housed in our OIG department. It really takes the lead,
crystal Lakora for in many of these initiatives, in explaining
what's happening in the community, in taking complaints, in putting out
as much information as we can so the public understands what the city of Houston
is doing. The next
slide gets we start getting into the numbers here.
It's the following slide the revenue
by funds and this is money
that comes in. So I'll get to the expenditures next. But this is the
revenue by funds and as you can see that there's
an increase in both the general fund and property and casualty.
Property and casualty fund revenue is just increased
to reflect the increased expenditures.
The general fund increase is due primarily to
vacancies. We've had an issue in being able to staff our
department. I think that's generally true of many
local government, public sector legal
departments. But here it has become
a big issue that I think we've been able to solve by having
market adjustments to increase.
I think the mayor worked with us and he did,
I thought, a remarkable job of being able to fund market increases.
So we are no longer at the bottom of the major cities in Texas
and then other major local government units
such as Metro, Harris County.
And the following slide reflects just what I was saying.
Right now, the revenue highlights.
The General Fund shows the vacancies of savings there
and then the property and casualty revenues to match the expenditures in the
funds. Now, the following slide gets
into expenditure by funds and
we go to the three major funds that I've discussed before.
As you can see, there's a bigger bump in
the Workers Comp Fund, but that's a smaller one. And so it's
probably better to explain that and these others in the following slides where
we can get into the details. But you can see here that the General Fund
has an increase of about 17% and about 6%
for the property and Casualty fund. So the following
slide, if you look at this,
you'll see the two dark bars toward the top.
What's in under that first bar is really the net
change to FY 2022.
And then below the second bar is the FY 2023
expenditure. So what you can see here is
we have an operating budget to begin with. Then you
add in the Hope adjustment,
then you have additional staff and pay adjustments.
So that is part of what I was talking about before with the increase.
And then below that you have restricted accounts. And restricted
accounts are it Application Data services.
The law has increasingly become dependent on technology
in order to be able to do the job that you need to do to
provide quality legal work.
Going below the second bar, if you look at the FY
2023, you can see there a reflection
of some of the remarks I've made to date.
The program adjustments are in the department market
salary increase, the additional staff
and pay adjustments, and then the parenthetical,
the 216. The negative just reflects a personnel transfer
from one fund to another. Then there are
contractual or mandated adjustments. That includes Hope,
again, restricted accounts and then health benefits make
up that last number, 44.
And so if you look at the difference between the two
budgets, that yields a 17% change.
This was set up to set questions for last. But if you have questions
at any point, please ask me. I don't want to overlook a slide where
it may be confusing to you. The following
slide slide ten. This is the highlights.
It's an important aspect of the increase is the market
salary increase to bring us up to competitive with
the other entities to
which we were losing attorneys, frankly, in addition to
the private sector. And then the funding that is required
to be made for health benefits, for hope and so on.
And then the funding for our outside counsel, litigation support,
claims and judgments.
The following slide number eleven is
this. Now I begin a series of charts to show where
the money is going within a fund. So this is the general fund.
If you look at the left, you'll see that
personnel makes up 92% of the costs. And that's very typical for any
legal department, law firm anywhere. That's generally where
you have a huge bulk of your cost. Non personnel is
8%. The pie chart to the right, where the arrow is
pointing, breaks down the non personnel. So you have the
restricted accounts that make up about half. And those
restricted accounts are the It applications, data Services,
voice Services, insurance Fees,
GIS, HR, client Services, things of that nature.
Then you have other services that make up 18%. And this
is Annex. Parking software, maintenance,
mail services, code of ordinance printing,
CLE bar dues. Travel supplies
are office and computer supplies. That's another 12%.
General Office Services. Those are in the nature of Westlaw
title data. And then paying the Harris
County Department of Ed for archived services, and then
the legal services. The 9% is outside counsel
that we use for immigration visas, artificial intelligence,
things of that nature. And then supplies are your standard
office and computer supplies.
The next slide, twelve shows the
property and casualty fund. And there
you see the numbers are reversed because
this is from which we pay our claims. So personnel makes up
only 35%, whereas non personnel makes up 65%.
And then looking at the pie chart to the right, you can see that
the bulk of the expenditures there
are anticipated for claims, settlements, judgments, attorneys fees,
legal services are outside counsel fees,
litigation support. Those are expert witnesses,
court reporters, medical services, document reading,
things of that nature. Then we have supplies and
restricted accounts, and then other services which were the
professional and membership fees, west law, travel, things of that nature.
Then the next slide shows the workers comp.
And as you can see, personnel makes up the bulk of that, about three,
four, and then non personnel is
about a fourth. And if you look at to the right,
you'll see that the restricted accounts, again, the It Application
Data Services, et cetera, make up the bulk of that supplies,
a small amount. And then the other services, the parking, the software,
and so on. So that's how the workers fund compensation
fund breaks down. So at this point,
I'm opening up to questions, and all I really have left after that
is just a glossary, our chart, and then
some demographic data and the department
accomplishments. Thank you,
Arturo, for your presentation. A couple
of questions. Try to explain to the public.
The main differences between your public law practice
and a private law practice? Are there things within your department that we are
significantly lacking as opposed
to a private law firm? Whether it's with software or any other applications,
certain law firms can afford the newest and the best technology
we have been able to manage. Obviously,
with more funds you can purchase more also
more of the technology so it's spread out among fewer people when
you do that. We have, for example,
body camera footage that has to be reviewed,
that has to be edited to pinpoint, to be able to present in
any litigation or any other matter. So you do have that constraint,
but we have been able to find
funds to get the software and the technology
we need, we think, to be able to do as good a
job as can be expected. Are there any outside of
the general fund opportunities for additional dollars or
funds that come into your department outside
of property casualty or general fund?
We sometimes recover funds. I mean, we did it,
we recovered funds for the city a significant amount when we
were sent defective masks during the pandemic. For example,
we recently settled the Allens Creek Reservoir matter
that we took issue with state legislation we
were able to prevail and we received,
even if it's not in direct dollars over time, what I think will
be substantial savings to the city. I think you had mentioned
in your presentation that the city of Houston at
one point in time was towards the bottom when it came to is that major
cities of competitive salary? Yes, that's right. That would be
San Antonio, Dallas, Fort Worth.
And also comparing locally here to Harris County and Metro.
Where are we now?
We're at the median. We're right there.
We think where we should be for the time being. And what are our efforts
for recruitment at the different law firms of the law
schools to try to attain the best talent?
Frankly, I think we need to probably take
a more direct approach to working with the local law schools, working with
the deans. I've had a couple of conversations.
We do get a lot of interest from
lawyers and we have been able to, I think,
hire some talented young lawyers from the local law
schools or who coming out of practice here. We do
sometimes have a bit difficulty trying to hire in some of the more
specialty areas, for example water rights or It technology.
Thank you. Next, we'll have questions by council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you. Vice Chair city Attorney. Michelle, first off,
just a huge thank you and
moment of gratitude to you and the entire team. I know that you break down
all the different specialties that your office takes care of,
but I don't think it's really hard to grasp
how much you all actually do day in and day
out, all of the different matters that you all have eyes on.
Remind me how many people are in your department,
roughly? I think we have about 170.
I know that's not precise, but that's okay.
But again, thank you, because I know we often see
items come up where we're seeking outside counsel, but that doesn't
take away from the extensive amount of work
that you all do. And thank you for always being so responsive to
my office on things. Really quickly,
the court backlogs and delays that we've seen that
the county is facing, how has that had an impact, if any,
on city related litigation?
I think it's primarily affected it in
two ways. One, I think our municipal courts, now that in
person hearings and trials are occurring,
you have a rush now because of the backlog, although it wasn't quite
what it was in the civil courts. What I think
we see in the civil courts in an area that we've had some
concern because we've been trying to staff, is really in the tort cases.
And so now that the courts are backlogged,
we're seeing more and more, and particularly when we need lawyers
and also paralegals, it's been difficult to find paralegals. It's difficult to
compete with the private sector, too. So I think that has just really
added to the constraints that
we have as a public entity law firm during the
pandemic. I know, for example, when lots of people are home,
we got at least the district offices, a lot more calls,
right, of issues and things like that. Did your office see a higher influx
or cases and issues remaining steady?
Yeah, I think that there were
particular challenges and different types of issues that had to
be raised, that we had to address. And I think much of that happened before
I arrived. And I think Deirdre Penny and Randy Zamora and the team
did an excellent job. Absolutely. And finally,
what are the needs, given the financial constraints that the
city continues to face, the revenue cap, et cetera?
What are the needs of the foreseeable future that we should be aware of that
aren't addressed in this in your budget this
year? I think if you had a wish list,
you would probably try to expand more in support
services within the department, paralegals the
ability to investigate claims, particularly in the neighborhood. For example, if you look
at neighborhood services, they filed eleven
Chapter 125 lawsuits. They've been successful
in challenging Sobs bars Spiveys on
Blodgett Street, for example. But those take time and
those take efforts in addition to what HPD provides.
Thank you. And if it would be possible, Vice Chair,
to put me back in queue, I'd appreciate it. Sure. I also want to
welcome Council Member Amy Peck, council Member Mary NAN Huffman,
and Council Member David Robinson to the chambers. Next,
we'll have questions and staff from District K and
District D council member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. And shout out to Randy Zamora
for all the good work he did on the noise ordinance sitting there behind you
on paper reduction. Legal is a
lot of paper. And are you all doing, DocuSigns? Are you all trying to cut
down on contract papers going back and forth? Can you describe a little bit
of your efforts there? Yeah, I think we
pay money to Harris County Department of Ed to archive, and we
need to go as paperless as possible.
That can't be done in all instances depending on what a
particular court you're in and what's being required.
We have that, but I think everyone in
the department is conscious of the need to use less paper.
It affects our bottom line, and frankly, it makes it more
efficient in being able to identify and find
something after the fact. So there's not really an
orchestrated effort. It's just kind of, let's try to do better,
or is there anything kind of in place to there is specific reduction
efforts. There is not a
plan. I'm going
to take that under advisement and look at it and see what other departments are
doing in order to do that. I do know that
it just makes us more efficient when we do that. And I think every lawyer,
our lawyers are frankly overwhelmed in what they have to do,
and they will always find ways to make it more efficient. But you bring up
a good point. Thank you.
That is a good point. I know that my law firm, we try to
be efficient with going paperless, but you kind
of are also very accustomed
to having those paper files in front of you and you like to grab them
and write notes and you know where they are. And sometimes
going paperless at a law firm, it sounds like it could be
more efficient, but sometimes it could be a little frustrating
as well. So I know that that balance is something that you all will continue
to consider and find a way to make it work.
Council member amy Abby Cayman.
Sorry,
it was a close one.
City Attorney as it relates to numbers
and metrics, it's hard, right? Some departments can have easy metrics.
Your department, what someone may think is a win
in court is actually a better win because we have a settlement,
less court costs, et cetera. Do you
track numbers and things like that? How much
dollars are generated from settlements, things of that nature that would be available?
Yeah, we do. Much of
our litigation is defensive, so you also would
have to look at the amount sought realistically,
what we felt a judge or jury could award, and if
we were able to settle for less things of that nature. We do
have litigation where we're the plaintiff that we
can look at that. But yeah, we do have that data. Okay,
again, just wondering. I think you all do a phenomenal job,
as council members mentioned,
randy, with the sound ordinance, the didras
as I like to say on multiple things. But again, the entire team just
really appreciate all of y'all's work. Thank you.
Well, again, we want to thank you for your presentation,
City Attorney Michelle, and to you and your entire staff for
all the contributions. We know you all do a lot with a little,
and you all do a great job of collaborating and engaging with our offices.
So continue the good work and thank you again, and you may be dismissed.
Thank you. We will now begin the
public comment period. We will start with our virtual
public speakers. Please press star six to unmute. When you
hear your name, the first speaker will be
Saba Blanding. Please press hi.
Good afternoon. Can you all hear me okay? Yes, ma'am.
Okay, wonderful. I had a few questions on slide
20. It says that the legal department negotiated police and
municipal employee union contracts. I was wondering if there's a
plan to make this process public like in other cities, and if
not, why? I was also curious when and how the
Office of Policing Reform and Accountability is planning
to implement community led recommendations around policing
beyond the mayor's appointees. I was also curious
council Member came and addressed this in an earlier department presentation.
But what are plans to extend the prenatal parental
and infant wellness leave ordinance? And finally,
I was personally curious about what percentage of funding, for one,
Safe Houston is outside of HPD. Particularly curious
about violence interruption and prevention measures and youth outreach. It makes sense how
it's set up on the website by an issue. But just in
terms of budgeting, I'm curious how the breakout is with departments.
Ms. Blanding, I'm going to give you some additional time because I know you were
kind of running through those questions so that we could
ensure that we got it all in the allotted time. But can you please repeat
question one and speak a little slower for
us? Yeah,
sorry. You know, I'm trying to get in, like, 23 questions.
My first question was that on slide 20, it says that the
legal department is the one that negotiates the police and municipal
Employees union contracts. And I was curious if
there's a plan to make this process public like in other cities,
including in Texas. And if not, why not?
That was my first question. So on that first question,
you are right. The city legal department does negotiate
with the Houston Police Officers Union. I think when it comes to
plans moving forward, that is something that will be discussed between the mayor
and the city attorney each
particular year on their vision and their perspective on what may be beneficial
for the city of Houston as it pertains to the negotiation process. We are
aware that other cities do have what may
be considered a more open process,
but those considerations lie solely with the mayor, his vision,
and working with the city attorney.
Did you need me to repeat my other questions. I know I was trying to
get them really quick. Yes, please.
Okay. I was getting a little winded too.
So my second question was when and how is the Office
of Policing Reform and Accountability planning to implement community
led recommendations around policing? So just beyond the appointees,
some more community led input? Yeah,
I think that's a great question, and I would like to see that as well.
I would request that the chair of the Public Safety Committee
kind of look into that somewhat to see if that's something we can get on
the schedule as a way in which we can take questions from
the public to be able to submit to that
oversight office and then be able to provide
some type of feedback. Or you can always reach out directly to your
specific district Council member on advocating
for that as well. For the District J office,
I can say that I would lean towards trying to find a way to collaborate
with Ms. O'core to do maybe a
virtual town hall where we can submit
some questions from the public and then be able to provide those answers.
Okay. And to repeat my third question, and this is more
to Council Member Cayman, perhaps you
addressed this in an earlier department presentation, but I was curious about any
plans to extend the prenatal Parental and Infant Wellness Leave Ordinance
saba as it relates to expansion of the paid parental
leave program. All City of
Houston employees are currently covered.
The mayor has asked and we as council members are encouraging
affiliated arms of the city that may not be within
council's direct control, for example, Metro, Houston, first, et cetera,
to begin looking at that for their employees as
well as for contractors, subcontractors,
et cetera. I do know that other work is being done by the Women's
Commission, but I cannot speak to that.
Okay, I appreciate that clarification about the process.
And then my final question was what percentage of funding for one
Safe Houston is outside of HPD? And I
was particularly curious about the violence interruption and prevention
measures and the youth outreach. So right now on the website,
it's broken down by domestic violence, which makes sense.
But as this is budget hearings and we're looking at particular
department budgets, I was curious to see those numbers by
department. So that was my final question, and I appreciate the time
to kind of repeat in a non rushed manner. Great question.
We will get that final answer for you
to make sure that we have the specific line items and broken down for you
in an itemized fashion. So please ensure that you
send that specific question over to the District E at houstontx
Gov and then we will respond promptly.
Thank you. Our next public speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver.
Oh, perfect. Okay, good afternoon,
everyone. So, first, let's see.
Okay, so I'm curious about the municipal,
the employee contracts as well and I also
know that the municipal contracts are a lot more transparent than,
say, the police union. And we haven't had fire negotiations
in a long time. But I'm curious about how much
in raises have been authorized for each of the three major employee
groups. I know that's a little bit detailed, so I'll make sure to
send that one in second. This is going
along with Council Member Pollard. I know you
brought the transparency dashboard project comport.
I'm curious about how many complaints have been received through
that dashboard and how can we bring
because it doesn't actually publish the complaints like Project Comport
does. I'm hoping that we can bring that back into the scope of
this new dashboard that's been put together. And then finally,
neighborhood support for deed restriction has
been a big need that I've heard from community members. I'm curious about
if it's possible to expand the types
of legal support that the department can offer to communities
and, like, civic clubs that are looking for deed restriction
support. All right, great question.
I believe on the employee contracts
fire, they receive 6% increase over
the next three years.
Police receive 4%, and municipal employees 3%.
As it pertains to the Police Transparency Dashboard,
those numbers are consistently being reevaluated.
And as you have a question to that,
wanting to know more about how many inquiries are coming into that
portal, so do I. And so I will be reaching out to Mr. Core for
those answers as well. And I think we need to do a better job
as a city in really highlighting the Police Transparency
Dashboard. That's something that I'm proud of, but not enough people
kind of understand the functionality of it, as well as
kind of how to navigate it and use it to their benefit. So I'm
going to put that on my shoulders to get
more engagement from the public and awareness on how to utilize
that. And my office will reach out
to you directly. I'm going to make a note of that so that we can
collaborate on getting some engagement. And then
your third question was the
increased deed restriction enforcement support.
So, of course, as you heard in the presentation earlier, our legal
department is spread pretty thin as it is with all of the different
practice areas that they cover. So to add on to
that with civic clubs or HOAs when it comes to D restrictions,
I think would be challenging. So we have to be creative in
our approach in working with Lone Star Legal Aid and others to
be able to bring forth those services to the public. I know in District J,
we have several entities like the India House
and Catholic Charities who provide weekend legal
services for residents at no cost. And so
we need to do a better job in maybe getting that
information out to our constituents. And so I would
request that everyone please sign up for your district council.
Members newsletters because they put a lot of good information
out there regarding those issues. And I know with the district J.
Pollard Press, we try to provide information
on free legal services each month for our residents as
well.
That concludes the public speakers list.